I will get up I will get up I'll get up
I'll get up I'll get
up okay it is
12 I don't know that is it is
1:28 um Friday September
29th my lease is done officially done
tomorrow I'm leaving
tomorrow and yeah
I got to do some packing a lot of the
things I have I honestly will be just
throwing away I'm a person who travels
pretty lightly usually when I move or
whatever it's really just like two
suitcases full of like clothes and
everything so pretty much same thing
here now the thing is though there are a
good amount of things I wanted to ship
to my parents house that um it's raining
like crazy if you're in your or around
New York you probably know it's raining
pretty bad um
so the UPS tour is a couple blocks away
and I'm like I do not I do not want to
go over there and do that there's really
just a couple of things left here I have
a lamp I have a coffee table a bench um
a mirror a beautiful mirror I love this
mirror so much I'm sad that you know
I'll be leaving it um I think somebody's
coming to pick it up so it should be
fine and I have a little like
bookcase is that about it I think that's
about it in terms of furniture so I'll
be okay throwing away most of these
things I need
to get dressed and do some filming for a
brand bad timing definitely but you know
let's do it it'll be fine no this is
really weird for me this is the first
time I'm
like really kind of living day by day to
be honest um I guess more like month by
month and it's been that way for a
couple months now um just making plans
one month at a time and just seeing how
I feel at the end of that month and
going from
there but yeah I'm going to Mexico City
for the month I have a really really
gorgeous like beautiful Airbnb that I'm
so excited to check out and I honestly
have no other plans other than just
recharging this last year in New York
has been 50 Shades of amazing and
exciting um but also like very like
difficult in some aspects I really
really appreciate the last year though
because like I saw more things than I
could have ever like thought I would see
I was on like every single Adventure
IM man imagin Jesus imaginable I went to
shows and you know clubs and partied and
cried and like had just not great things
happened but had really amazing things
happen like I really no one can say I
did not live up my year um and honestly
when I think about what people think of
when they think of New York like let's
say I was watching like a New York movie
of a 20 something person um I my last
year very much lives up to that um and
more like you don't want a movie to just
be good like amazing the whole time like
you want it to have a plot and you know
drawbacks and questions and fear and all
these other things and my year
definitely had that so like I'm
extremely grateful for this year that
being said I am extremely excited for
like what there could be away from this
year not even like away from New York
like away from this year like everything
that has happened in the last year I am
content with packaging it up and like
leaving it there um and so now it's like
okay so what what's next then and it's
hilarious because like I literally
complained about New York City like
pretty much every day that I was here
except for the last like six weeks and
like people say like hey like your first
year in New York City is going to be
grueling and testing like the the
universe knows your demons and will pull
it right out and shove it in your face
if you live in New York City and that's
what happened to me um and I felt it all
the way through and so for a very long
Tel I was like I want to leave I want to
leave I want to leave I I want peace
there's no peace here I'm like I'm just
not having a good time but over the last
few weeks like 6 weeks or so there's
definitely been a change in perspective
where like it's very difficult here and
I'm probably still going to feel it
difficult but I started seeing more of
the magic of New York again I think it's
because um I've been wanting to be more
creative in my next chapter I want to be
really really Allin into content but
also Arts I I really want to paint I
really want to dance and be Musical and
take classes for different things and
now I'm like I don't know if Mexico City
if that's the place to do that because
like New York is Arts capital of the
world you know so I don't
know if leaving it will be the right
choice for me cuz that's really where my
mind has been L specific on Arts so
again this month is going to be very
much looking for Clarity on things
okay let's go film so usually I film in
front of this window I'm not wearing
official bottoms because you know what
we're not seeing that part so it's
fine okay I really liked that um I'm
actually shocked at how quickly I was
able to talk through it cuz I really do
love this brand and I want y'all to be
able to like use their resources and
their tools and so let me do some
editing real quick it's so loud because
of the rain and so and because of the
echo so I need to put in some noise
reducing like
software and yeah hopefully it gets to a
place that I'm like okay that's good let
me submit it for a review so let's see
okay I just submitted the um videos for
the brand look over I'm kind of tired to
be honest though um the rain's lightened
up and I think this is a good time for
me to run over to the
UPS okay that was not so bad at all the
man who helped me was
extremely extremely nice I wish him
nothing nothing but the best for him and
everyone he loves but yeah I asked I was
like how much would like a 20x 20 box
filled with clothes be like to ship and
I said like to Denver how much would
that be and he's like oh like the
standard rate with you know anybody
would be about $60 I bought three
boxes this is how big they are so I
bought three of these cuz I'm like no
way am I shipping more than
$360 boxes cuz that's now $180 before
tax and everything and that was just an
estimate so I'm going to like also like
really really be mindful about what I'm
taking because like I need it needs to
have a value in my head of at least
$60 um or not even the item but like the
box in general it's like okay if I had
to put a value to all the items in here
would I say it's $60 and if I can't say
yes then something's not getting shipped
so that's pretty much all of this and
again it's mostly just clothes there's
going to be some shoes that I need to
put away that's definitely going to be
like one solid box
but yeah don't mind these because this
these I'm taking with me so so it's
really everything on the
perimeter um minus the bedding the
bedding I'm just going to throw away I
just feel bad throwing away right now I
think I'll wait till the last minute to
throw it away so it's really just these
items so I don't don't even think I'll
need the three bags um I mean the three
boxes maybe just like I don't even know
one one and a half and so I really don't
think it's going to take a lot a long
time I'm tired I'm going to take a break
oh
my this is watch let's watch some love
is blind I think hold on yo I need to
see this um the honeymoon episode The
like preh honeymoon oh this is
about to be a whole of his
blind
thing like it just really helps that
she's like so hot okay move to the
kitchen cuz I have things to do
I need to um remove the
dent on this purse so I just put the
teac kettle
on and I'm just going to I'm just going
to like hold it over it to like steam it
a little
bit I'm going to proceed
to clean this kitchen some
more um
yeah while watching Love is bun I'm
still watching it it
is right up here so
[Music]
yeah not him saying well if you look
like this I would love
it I do look like like he said she
hasn't put on makeup up since that day
and you've seen me every day since she
doesn't have makeup on so what's the
issue
[Music]
wow
this is where we're at so like honestly
just finishing touches the main problem
is this room specifically because of the
bathroom well go go to the roof take up
that amazing view and go to
bed okay so it's the next
day I'm pretty much packed I'm trying so
hard to close this and I can't get it
closed and I'm getting very
frustrated no okay I'm going
to take this
out and move this to
here
um that's going to have to do let me you
know I'll just throw this away
it okay now honestly I'm just throwing
things into boxes I don't even care
anymore here let me just close it and
maybe I'll tape it at the
facility because I don't want to like in
case I need to open it up again again
for something so for now let me just
close it I'm going to call an
Uber to help me drop these off and then
I have this bag of books that I'm going
to donate to the like little cute
Library
um I'll open this oh my gosh I'm
exhausted I have not
eaten it is just before 12:30 so I'm
running behind cuz I wanted to leave by
so let me bring these boxes
downstairs and call the Uber to get me
to the post
[Music]
office okay so
I um just took the boxes to
USPS I'm extremely just not doing well
right now the USPS took a very very long
time like it took an hour I thought it
was going to be
just drop it off but it took an hour
because of how first trying to get an
Uber that would fit the boxes and
then getting the boxes inside and
everything people helped me which I'm so
grateful for
okay
um I will
like a permanent home so
bad and I think
like I'm treating going to Mexico very
much as an
intermission and trying to figure out
where I'm going to go and where I'm
going to be it sucks cuz like there's so
many wrong choices or right choices that
are wrong still in some way and it's
hard for me
to make a decision and just stick with
it but I really am sick and tired of
moving around so much I have not
stayed in a place for this now actually
is the longest I've stayed somewhere in
like I think like 4
years and I was here for like 10
months 9
months and before that I stayed mad Max
like 6 months places at a time for the
last like yeah for the last like 4 years
I just
want just be settled
somewhere and
have a community
somewhere and just
not feel so alone
[Music]
everywhere I'm going to
close my suitcase
and um
put
my I
away
okay okay okay okay I will get up I will
get up I'll get up I'll get up I'll get
up I get up
okay okay this is me getting up I'm
getting up I'm getting
up
okay
not going to lie I was relying heavily
on having inlight Wi-Fi to help me pass
the time I was going to spend
whatever was needed to get inlight Wi-Fi
and they're they're claiming there is
like free Wi-Fi but that's the worst Wii
that's the worst WiFi y'all should see
my setup I don't know how I ever not
have three seats to myself on a
plane and I don't even know how that
happened because my seat wasn't assigned
until I was we were boarding I had to
like go to the gate agent and get the a
seat and I was happy that it was a
window seat but then I get here and we
take off and it clicks I'm like wait a
damn minute there's no one next to me so
I have food here movie here elephant
here
drinks
purse and
electronics to be honest I would prefer
this over at first class I I am in
luxury
once uh oh we're on the
road the only thing left to like that's
like really like on my mind is getting
the hotel reservation cuz I didn't I
haven't gone there yet it's this
um like specifically like local um hotel
which I stayed in for a couple nights
last year um due to a hilarious story
that I can talk about later but I had to
fle my Airbnb and go to this hotel and
it was so ridiculously cheap it was like
I think like $15 a night but still so
gorgeous so um yeah I I'm hoping they
have room I remember last time I booked
it the day before not even the day
before last time I booked it the day of
and so I was just going to do the same
thing and pray for the best I only need
it for one night cuz my airb be check in
is at 3: uh tomorrow
[Music]
so okay so the
hotel does not have and so I hit up my
airb host
and he is letting me check in early my U
is almost here so yes let's
go oh my goodness okay we made it I'm so
tired I believe it's just before
midnight my Airbnb host was kind enough
to open up the apartment a day early so
I'm really really grateful for that this
apartment is so cute um but now I'm just
itching to see it in the day because
like the lighting isn't great and so I
really want to see it during the day
because it has like these huge like
screen doors and like that makes up most
of like the like most of not all of the
wall both upstairs and upstairs and
downstairs um I can't think y so I'm
very excited to see it during the day
something I did not think about was
Cooling and I don't know if there's bugs
because I would open the screen door but
there's no netting so I'm trying to
think like should I open the screen door
to let some of the cool air
in or no I don't know about that but um
yeah I think for the rest of the night
I'm going
to do quite a bit of editing because I
really want this video up by tomorrow
afternoon so yeah I'll just put on some
TV
and yeah yeah thank you so much for
coming along with me over these last few
days cuz it's been a ride it's been a
lot but I'm
excited right now I'm just more tired
but yeah yeah checking with me in the
morning yeah